if me and Anthony commit a crime don't
ever say that you guys are gonna go down
with them I never say not on my watch I
go it could happen on my watch
if I got any allegations that come my
way I'm like I'm the JK guy you know all
of us we all go to jail dude
[Music]
all right you guys know those like
[__] giant ships think of like a
Titanic right and you know how like they
got those like little onboarding ramps
those little uh the ones that Leonardo
Dicaprio and his homie Fabrizio or
whatever and they were like they were
late right in the Titanic was about to
boring they're running they're like no
no we're Americans we don't you remember
that [__] yeah oh yeah so imagine
there's a situation right where this
dude
apparently it was already on the boat
something happened he had to run off I
don't know if he had to like get some
whatever but nobody knows what happened
right yeah so this guy runs back to
trying to get back on but it's at a
point where it's like the boat's
starting to leave right guys guys trying
to come back on crew members like no you
can't come on right now right and then
he's like no but I gotta come on and
then he steps on I stiff arms him again
and he [__] falls into the water and
he drowns no oh [__] that's what
happened cause he can't swim he can't
swim is that why apparently there's a
possibility that and again they don't
know because it all happened so fast
that he might have fallen and like hit
his head on like you know part of the
dock or something went into the water
unconscious or just drowned or hit some
or some sort of impact maybe to his head
the water around the Dot's nasty as [__]
too it looks like straight coolant I
hate people who like take their jobs too
seriously it's just like it's like
what's the point like he's literally on
you're gonna shut like that's just crazy
especially like in a situation like that
where like just safety is an order yeah
because if you want to kill the guy you
got to wait until the boat is out in the
middle International it's all you're
trying to stop him from getting on to
like a amusement park ride yeah plus
it's like if he was already on too it's
like oh [__] okay you shouldn't do this
but like get the [__] on Carnival Cruise
this is actually no this is actually an
inter island ferry known as the Blue
Horizon so it's basically just a ferry
that's taking you to Catalina oh that's
[__] up bro just die that way it's
horrid yeah so four crew members
responsible are facing charges related
to their involvement and altercation
that results in the death of 36 year old
individual Antonis cardiotis oh so sad
that's a fake name dude are they
Italians I have no idea that's so sad
that's not a rule he had he had a ticket
he just disembarked the ship for
undisclosed reasons and maybe he had to
take a dookie there might be a there
might be a dookie spot on the ferry yeah
have you guys ever been on a ferry where
you could take your car on and then you
go that sounds fun huh I want to do it
it does sound kind of fun I did a
European tour where the tour bus drives
on the ferry oh I have done that yeah
and then the ferry goes from uh I think
London to Paris and then we get back on
the tour bus and then it keeps driving
that's cool they used to have one in
Hawaii that went to uh the islands in
between where you could take your car
and everything and then they uh they're
like oh you're destroying the [__]
whales or some [__] right the [__]
way yeah like they were saying some
stuff like that so then this is the
funny thing right so they had to
decommission it because the
environmentalist didn't like it but what
ended up happening is they sold it to
the military and now the military is
just using it inner island in Hawaii
so it's still being used but they're not
killing the whales though hate the [__]
right that's the same [__] the killing
whales because of the oil and stuff or
is it because of like the propeller like
slicing they said that it it's not
actually killing the whales but it can
hurt them if it hits them
I guess that's
there's just like for prevention or
whatever but the point is it's still
being used it's not like they stopped it
completely it's just now not being used
for you know civilian
I don't know this guy have family
um
that's a knit question Nick is like I
hope they do so then they suffer next
question is like did he have any Jolly
Ranchers in his pocket what color shirt
was he wearing exactly do you think he
had water shoes on that's a good
question though that's true that would
have helped them not around you think it
was Divas or more Nick questions more
Nick questions but also let's blame the
victim a little bit should you have
tried to been like running around
jumping aggressively in a body of water
which you don't know how to swim in this
is why you boats have rules dude again
coronary reports indicate that Mr
cardiotis drowned with a small contusion
on his head suggesting he likely hit the
dock or the ramp when he fell some
passengers aboard the ferry even claimed
that one of the propellers struck him on
the head when he felt oh [__] how do
they [__] know that imagine though
death by propeller that's fine wouldn't
that be way worse than just a small
contusion on your head I think that
might be I think it's worse if he
doesn't die instantly yeah I'd actually
try to jump on it if you get hit and it
just like happens pretty quickly but
what if it's like not here what if it's
like yeah like what it was just like
you're drowning and you're bleeding out
in pain that's [__] I don't know
you're seeing your organs come out and
then mackerels come and start biting on
you and then all the other divers are
coming like ooh fish
I think I would have aggressively tried
to get back on board if I had a ticket
and I'm in an area that I'm just like
what the [__] I don't want to be
stranded here I don't even understand
the situation like if you were on a
cruise right and let's say you're like
an Ensenada and [__] and they're like
nah you can't come back on and it's like
no I'm not staying here yeah all my
shit's in there yeah what the [__] dude
and I would I would try to jump on don't
they do like head counts and everything
too they're pretty [__] strict about
that stuff yeah but this is a fairy so
they didn't have a list that's true yeah
they probably didn't have like a you're
not here they could probably have the
wristband
this is in Greece I believe not
organized over there they don't know
what they're doing dude I'll push you
off the boat dude see the grease guys
are just like these what kind of charges
are these guys facing do you know the
captain is facing charges related to
dangerous navigation while the crew
member responsible for pushing him is
charged with manslaughter
whoa why is the captain getting in
trouble the other two crew members who
were bystanders are accused of complicit
complicity in manslaughter oh no why did
it push the guy isn't that full just at
the next the giant steering wheel what
does he have to do with it yeah dude
he's looking at maps and [__] hey maybe
it's always a top-down thing you know
like uh the leaders in in charge of
everything regardless if it happens on
his boat like that dude just standing
there could have done anything to help
anyways anybody who gets to say it not
on my watch is like responsible
um because it's happened on their watch
I mean that's why I never say that if me
and Anthony commit a crime don't ever
say that you guys are gonna go down with
us I never say not on my watch I go it
could happen on my watch
if I got any allegations that come my
way I'm like I'm the JK okay guy you
know all of us we all go to jail dude
we're all going to jail because just
kidding news taught me I'd never say
that because I know I'm not very
watchful
nobody watches me damn that's really
unfortunate Anthony what would you do if
you were the guy and there was which guy
the guy who dies no the other guy if
you're dealing with a unruly customer
that's who's like I gotta get on that
boat and you're like sorry pal anchors
up now that I've read this news article
brought to you by JK what would you do
Anthony would reach out I'm like grab my
hand yeah I'll definitely make it a cool
scene you know I'd be the hero for sure
I mean look if you tried the first time
because he apparently tried the first
time they successfully pushed
successfully pushed him off and then on
his second attempt to board is when he
was pushed and fell into the water I
think on a second attempt like he said
it's just a [__] fairy ride it's like
it's like all the trains in like Japan
and stuff like that or what or anywhere
you jump on the train you don't have a
ticket you're still on the train nobody
gives a [__] and then the guy who comes
around and take it to you is like oh you
don't have a ticket you're gonna get
fined yeah yeah yeah yeah but you're
still on the train rather than falling
between the cracks and dying yeah for
sure you know what I mean like no matter
what if you get on you can anybody can
get on those trains you just need to
have a ticket why didn't he wear the
life jacket when he ran off the boat
why'd he run off in the first place yeah
maybe he was just an obnoxious dude that
they didn't want him back on yeah or
what if he just dropped his phone or his
keys and he's like oh I have to get it
what no matter how innocent the
situation if the if the boat if there's
a danger zone and you jump if the boat's
not moving there's a [__] to be to go
on that ramp means there's a pocket of
danger you can't be [__] physically
altercating with a human being in that
space maybe he watches like Ultimate
Ninja Warrior and he's like I can make
that jump he's watching on TV and he's
like yo I could do that yeah he went for
it and then just regardless of the rules
yeah I I do have I do have to say it's
it's probably poor you know the crew
members like I do understand how they're
technically at fault for this you know
well maybe the guy doing his job got
railed his boss that sounds bad but damn
we're able to buy his boss in like not
doing his job the day before so today
he's like I'm gonna really do my job and
then he and he's like you're gonna get
fired and this guy has been looking for
work for days because he's that guy
who's like you know it's a Prohibition
era over there and they're just like
waiting like they hire me today exactly
with the tickets I get it I get it
you could have let him like 12 people
the night before he goes you always let
[__] on he's like all right
today I won't let nobody
this guy did have a ticket so yeah he
still had to take it I don't know I see
yeah yeah you got a little bit I still
feel like it's like you can't do your
job too well to where it's like it's
endangering someone he's a doorman dude
that's what that guy is yeah he's a
bouncer yeah I think this guy his
problem the guy that died his problem is
he was dressed like a pirate and then
the crew member was like we ain't gonna
let these pirates on this board and then
he's like I gotta
stole that from someone else leave it up
to Jake
Somali no I'm talking about horror
Pirates
[__] wooden leg and everything
Captain Hook pirate you're like if we
let this pirate on board he's gonna take
it off Joe's a doorman and a [__]
Captain Hook comes she's like come on in
it's like oh my God Captain Hook dude
yeah
because you know he's not making a jump
with that piglet you gotta let him in
foreign
[Music]